beach mumbai's most popular place to go
swimming
or do anything else that's fun in the
fresh air
from cotton candy to roast corn on the
cob
choice of fast food is enormous but the
most popular snack
is pauwatchi fried bread with vegetables
and tomato sauce
where the legendary hero rama proudly
shows himself with his weapons
at the srirama snack bar
the heroes behind the pots and pans are
uttam
and his co-worker rashendra they're
stirring a very special mixture made
according to the house recipe
tomato onion capsicum
there are no tables but there is a
waiter customers get good service
used to be poor people's food eaten by
workers in mumbai's textile mills at
their lunch breaks
it's still relatively cheap the
equivalent of about a euro
but it's really tasty
it's very spicy and we often come here
it's holiday time and everyone likes
property
it's a famous dish of mumbai
the manager sharma originally comes from
northern india
he's run the sri rama snack bar for more
than 25 years
what's special about us is that the
customers can watch how we prepare
pao bhaji
but right now i'm testing to see if it
tastes right
and it has to be because hungry
beachgoers will be flocking to the snack
bar
dedicated to the hirorama until deep
into the night